unreal unplayable just as good as messi
when it comes to dribbling weaving weave
in and out three and four players unless
he's five foot seven hold up you just
said he's gonna meet you
he was just as he's just as good as good
he would we please go and you said
earlier when you look at youtube please
i've watched i've got christian live
i've watched him many many times ago
then you know then like oh no he's not
as good as in dribbling
[Music]
it's a statement and half in it
just the truth mate
this is playground well that's what
that's what today is to define isn't it
exactly that's fine russ stand up and
show you through the camera your shirt
here show the camera your shirt it says
it's just this playground
it's a bit weathered mate that must have
been before christiano got
there it was definitely when he was
there that's it yeah let me show you how
dedicated i am to messi
great it's a nice tattoo
unfortunately
you picked the
guy wrong
unfortunately mate i didn't
oh my god i know a couple of good laser
guys i'll continue them
[Music]
we're gonna get there leonardo messi is
the best player in football history
three
two
one
he's not in the best players to play for
argentina
really
he's not no okay he's not why is that
then
argentina historically
have won two world cups 14 copper
americas
this guy's only just won a copper
america okay if he's that good yeah why
is it taking him six tournaments to do
it
maradona's been showboating third fee
for years how old are you i'm 31 31 yeah
how old did you win maradona's plan adam
how old was you in maradona i probably
wasn't born you're right you wasn't one
but argentina are like brazil yeah like
a spain they're known as an
international how many times you watch
maradona play haven't you haven't and
you're making that statement well that's
what people go on when people talk about
the greatest of all time
bearing in mind people are going on
there
to talk about watching we've got our
nines to talk about have you watched him
i haven't you just told me marathon you
just told me maradona you've never seen
him play never see never seen pele play
never seen that that's one strongly
strongly strongly disagree okay if chris
if it was cristiano i'd probably if if
she was another foot yeah
i'd probably be
around here somewhere you know what you
need to do with the orange juice because
i can't i can't make that assumption
you just did
line up how can you say i strongly agree
okay have you have you seen these guys
have you seen them
i've ever watched that wasn't the
question
that wasn't like can someone read the
question out again please hello
hold on i want to hear this can we can
we have the question one more time
please i'll repeat the questions thank
you thank you leonardo messi is the best
player in football history yeah in
football history yeah so ever has
football just been going on for the last
just understand that's why he's above
every single person but a minute ago
i wasn't allowed to put maradona
slightly ahead of the curve because i've
never seen him playing the stats not
better than his we put you a minute ago
my
argument is lionel messi's stats are
better than anyone everyone have you
seen pelo play
no see okay i heard about pele when he
scored 27 goals in like a farmer's
league and when he was playing against
milkman and stuff like that so i need to
talk about farmers leagues popcorn or
black but anyway yeah so rob rossman
what give me give your point as to why
you think messi is the greatest player
of all time he scored more goals scored
more goes than what he's scored context
plays more goals than anyone the most
assists he's passing he's dribbling his
assists he's pre-assisted he makes
players around him better neymar suarez
the last three ballon d'ors messi has
been without them players two two and
he's won two without jeffy
and he's won two of them um
he makes everyone better around him
i've watched him live 300 times plus to
know what i'm seeing
and there is any player even a fraction
a fraction as good as him the first
comment you said earlier on
he scored more goals than anyone mm-hmm
you're wrong straight away okay sorry
i'll rephrase what i just said he has a
better goal ratio than the person you're
obsessed with that's fine i mean i
haven't mentioned his name yet but
that's fine
um
you've you've mentioned
frodo bagging his name a lot of times
today so that's fine because you're
obsessed with goals i'm going to give
you something to think about
okay bring some assistance and just just
make sure you have a think about this
one
if lionel messi doesn't score for three
seasons three whole seasons he still has
a better goal ratio than cristiano
ronaldo in what again in one context
stop talking about context you have to
put context if he doesn't score for
three seasons he still has a better goal
ratio than him if he doesn't play the
games and obviously no no no if he
doesn't messy doesn't need to score for
three whole seasons and he still has a
better goal ratio but obviously because
he's not playing the games what you want
if he's playing the game there we go
he played every single game for the next
three seasons he'd still have a better
goal ratio have a think about that in
what in the league
or overall or it's not overall
in three years he played three seasons
christian has only played two more
seasons he's played 156 more games than
lionel messi it's two seasons and you
know messi's only 43 goals behind him
yep
again again
earlier on you were talking about ballon
d'ors that's right she's got more ballon
d'ors and chaffee and iniesta yeah that
doesn't make him better than me
michael owen's got more ballon d'ors
than cheer on reid doesn't make it we're
going to use that one are we
listening
cristiano ronaldo is a better player
than leona messi
jesus
i'm not sure he went all the way over
there
they're both
they are both don't forget the question
was player player yeah they are both
the
best two players of of my my generation
okay i don't know how old you are
patreon's obviously been pretty bad but
um
i'm categorically certain it's cristiano
just because of
some of the things he's done in the
champions league
and and internationally these are things
that you know they're going to be talked
about more than what lionel's done he's
done great things but
the things that cristiano has done are
going to be talked about more in future
years to come and what he's done for his
team and where he's dragged them the
question was players you know do you
know what that means yes that means all
context of the game not just goals but
that means winning big titles and i say
big titles and when you first answered
this question you threw in a personal
insult
and the first sign of a weak argument is
when you start getting personal
and that's what you've just done
i was just clarifying that your
generation might you might have gone to
a different generation as a goal scorer
he's phenomenal yeah he's the second
best goal scorer behind messi he's
phenomenal like he's ridiculous goal
scorer as a player
i'd rather chew on wood than watch him
he's abysmal to watch i'd rather watch
something like bernardo silva than him
he excites me gets out of my chair and
now now you were jet you know when
ronaldo was better when he first was at
man united i went to a few games
through knowing a ticket and i went to a
few games and he was so much better than
winger tricky skillful that's what age
does to you no i don't know even at real
madrid he's not great to watch he's
not great to watch i'd say no he wasn't
i'm not going to sit here and lie and
say that he wasn't
like i'm so sick of this oh ronaldo
can't dribble and stuff
you hit the nail on the head he's when
he was at united and probably his first
four or five seasons at madrid
unreal unplayable just as good as messi
when it comes to dribbling weaving weave
in and out three and four players
messi's five foot seven hold up you just
said he was listening to me you you just
he was just as he's just as good as
that's good he would we please go and
you said earlier when you look at
youtube please now i've watched i've got
chris
live i've watched him many many times
you know then like oh no he's not as
good as in dribbling intent
my god the guy used to just fly past
people and then i'd probably say you got
injured in 2014. we'll never know we
won't know till he retires what what
actually happened but you can see there
was a definite decline there in terms of
his dribbling and things like that i
reckon if he didn't get an injury he
would have been better messy dribbling
that for sure if he didn't get that
injury great thanks no i think he would
have yeah i mean you must have been
smoking stuff to come out and stuff like
that what do you mean to come out with
he was as good as addressing as good as
good you this is banter right no it's
not banner it has to be banner no you're
even a wine up there and someone over
there telling you to say this stuff you
obviously haven't watched as many videos
as you said that you've watched i don't
watch videos i've watched him live he
was absolutely flying past people at man
united i just said that to you he was in
he was madrid madrid
i watched him plenty he was further up
the pitch for madrid so he didn't start
as deep and he wasn't you know running
at them with a bit of pace behind him
he was
as good on now you should be arrested
for that
you should be arrested you should be
there they were both that's a criminal
offense to say something same level same
level when it comes to dribbling 100
100 all right the pro the problem is now
is we haven't seen cristiano do a lot of
that probably
i'm going to put a date on it around
2014. so a lot of people now forget what
he used to be able to do
and if anything that makes him a better
player because he's been able to evolve
when other players have struggled when
they've lost when they've lost a yard or
two they've just a bit lost a bit of
pace they've struggled to attack and
messi's evolved or not he hasn't had to
evolve because to be fair to he hasn't
had to evolve he hasn't had to
he hasn't where did he where did he
first play for barcelona
he came through the ranks i said where
what position
uh he started as a right winger uh right
winger right winger and then bearing in
mind you know i've been to over 300
games sometimes he's playing as a
central midfielder as a pivot getting
the ball off the center heart drops
harry kane drops he's got a striker
isn't he okay but he's easy
drops as well
when he drops it's embarrassing because
he starts pretending he's a playmaker
and he's certainly he's not so what he's
done for portugal the cheerleader that's
outrageous
okay
now can i put something into context for
you you may okay yeah who's he been
playing against for this uh portugal
team i'm so glad you asked that question
i'm so glad it's good should we stay on
the international bit for a while
because i could be here all day
internationally
you know let's down and let's stay on it
how many top ten teams messi scored
against in um in in major competitions
in major i'll help you it's this number
okay and it's this number 20
it's this number okay ronaldo scored
like 14. so goals against andorra in one
game probably no idol's not the top 20
you know why he's not the top when he
finished a week sixth wasn't it
in
[Music]
by the way he's up here and the copper
america is the cobra member
it's not very good and what the euros
are the euros is much better okay so
let's let's we're going to put things
into context again
so we've got he's been beaten in four
finals yeah and the one world cup final
so he you're not going to do a spurs do
are you no no no birds do this it wasn't
what the spurs first go
uh oh yeah but remember that final we
got two that's great you've got the mvp
player is that that world
no never know has he ever got to a final
you're doing what spurs do
the
yeah
team to a final that contained was it
demi-kellis and zabaleta did he ever
drag a team like that to a final i said
i think i said the stats anyone about
argentina i'm putting things into
context for you no no no no
you just said a pathetic team
argentina have got 14 copper americas
pre-christiana uh pre-medicine and and
two world cups we want to talk about
what the other guy's done for his
country
75 years prior to ronaldo being there
three champions uh three euros and three
world cups and it's all down to portugal
qualified qualified for
he's over exceeded that they've done
four and five now is he qualified world
cup next year he hasn't
not yet they haven't yet no well let's
get back to this international this
international talk please i'm even going
to go as far as saying the nation's
league
is the nation's league it's harder to
win than the copper america oh is that
because cristiano underneath no no no i
actually i actually went to the final
importer in 2009 well you might as well
just say messi won the olympics in if
you're going to mention nations league
oh my god nation's league the nations
league yeah it's pathetic should we
break them both down so we'll break the
cop we'll break the copper down we'll
break with now the cup of america's on
par with the euros that's what it's the
equivalent of the copper american if you
are going to do you know why the
nation's league started go on tell me
somehow cristiano has played in five
euros yesterday he started in two hours
i haven't finished cristiano has played
in five euros started in 2004. this is
played in six copa americas only started
in 2007. how has that happened the cop
did the economy ball wake up in january
and go
should we pick some straws out should we
do it should we do it
i don't know how it rolls
but it's not very reputable you know we
did they did you always every four years
well they're talking about it now
they're talking about doing every two
years now no keep every four because it
you know it makes people look forward to
it they do every two years imagine how
many girls christian can score against
andorra and kazakhstan he complains he's
about 70. messi winning the ballon d'or
this year was a farce
three
two
one
i knew this was going to come up today i
knew that we would be coming in and now
talking about his seventh one because
it's also run by france football now
france football have wanted to be
relevant for such a long time he spent
220 million on neymar so that's why he
won it that's not why he won it but you
can see that psg and france football
want to try and be relevant
because he won't plan for psg no he
wasn't at the time but now do you know
what he's doing he's just got there you
know what dates they run from it's it's
annually i'll tell you january the first
off yeah it's annually yeah so he's
playing for barcelona yeah for most of
them at barcelona yeah and obviously
copper america for argentina now for
years
people have gone he doesn't deserve it
he hasn't won interviews
why has he won that one he didn't win an
international trophy hold up a minute he
wins it and suddenly doesn't deserve it
we can all win trophies that just aren't
very good christian's pretty good
carabao cup mesa got some copper del
reys
we just don't talk about them in 20
years time no one will talk about their
ballon d'ors they'll talk about what
they did internationally and about what
they did for the champions league and
things like that that's what people will
talk about
that's all we talk about the goat the
greatest of all time
gone he the ballon d'ors are fast on all
accounts i asked you earlier on is
moderates better than jeffy and iniesta
not in any lifetime but you can see that
just by watching them with a pair of
eyes but i don't need to again lemon
dusty doesn't have something to say this
season now lands you should have
won it last year but not this year
statistically he's been better than
lewandowski this year he hasn't yet
okay one league goal okay you're
probably the same person that will argue
that harry kane is better than
lewandowski because lewandowski plays in
the farmers league now we both know that
lewandowski is a forward center forward
he's phenomenal and he should have won
the ballon d'or last year
whether you think it's a fast or not he
should have won it last year but this
year statistically he wasn't better than
him it's as simple as that
the facts are he wasn't better than him
most assists top scorer mvp five of the
six matches he's man of the match what
do you want him to do five or what six
matches in the copper america
right i don't think you should have won
on i know you're saying he won an
international trophy that is in 2016 he
got robbed of the ballon d'or and he
scored more goals and assists than
anyone and he didn't win it
because his lionel messi it doesn't
matter
didn't christiana win the champions
league
and the euros he had more goals and
assists than anyone that yeah
but he's because the way you're going on
about it with lewandowski you're going
on it based on goals because you can't
be going on about anything else you're
not going to tell me he's a wonderful
footballer to watch no because
he tells you he he deserves that on
merrick no what i'm saying to you is
you're talking about his goals obviously
i know that you're talking about his
goals messi's more than goals he's more
than goals and i know you've watched him
i know i think this is one big joke with
you today i think it's banter and i
generally know that you think messi's
better christianity
thank you very much
is that when he has a shot and he's
going like five meters wide and someone
taps it in his classes he's your time
assist maker in the champions league is
it christian he's playing about 657 000
games in here he's he's played two
seasons more worth of games yeah but
again
united he played anyway the bottom line
is the ballon d'or this year he got it
and he deserved it you're basing on
certainly so fast and because he plays
for paris now utter the question
so i think lad bible already knows so
fast and the amount of actually they run
the ballon d'or then they don't know the
amount of real footballers not
journalists have come out after that
vote and said
i'm glad missy won it because this year
they've been able to go real footballers
are gone you know what
i'm gonna take this mickey mouse i'm not
taking this that seriously anymore but
you've been taking like that for years
you said right
next question after this question i'm
just gonna add in there a lot of people
don't think about there's a farce where
we are just uh don't call that me out
i've got a recording
you asked me
you must think it no no we have to
freeze it one way or the other to be
agree or disagree we can both agree
that messi and ronaldo are great
i players i think
i think they're both phenomenal players
unless he's the best as simple as that
sure opinion it's not as a fact you
shouldn't talk to it it's a fact
it's a fact christian will be remembered
for he's done way more than what missy's
done i'm afraid champions leagues are
internationally and that's what i'm
putting it down you need to have to
smoke
can we just get a shake of the hands and
a good uh well well nice to meet you
guys nice to meet you
i was the angriest episode i've ever had
okay
hey say what yeah there's a great place
league with barcelona
he went to barcelona and he caught la
liga and uh i say he beat man united in
the final with pep 2009 so we're now
done we got one more he got a champions
league trophy more than you ronaldo one
ballon d'or in that yeah um real madrid
is thierry henry won a ballon d'or